there's time and place for everything
and I it's weird because you're saying
that we're connecting we're connecting
doesn't sound like it they'll dude no
it's this is what happens to young boys
right it's like you get so in the fields
yeah and you're so excited that you're
not watching the [ __ ] that's coming out
of your mouth and you think just because
you're excited and you're sharing your
excitement with them that they feel the
same that is not a connection that is
you jerking off yeah that is you feeling
so good you gotta express yourself
mm-hmm but you got to pay attention do
they feel the same are they connecting
to you at this moment yeah if I was him
and and and I was clueless clueless I
this is what I would have done Oh baby
you look so good when you [ __ ] show
your cleavage when you stream and I'm
and that's why you get so many views and
this is extreme but I'm saying to that
effect that's what they hear yeah when
you go you need a stream more cuz oh man
like you saw you so [ __ ] hot girl
that's not the [ __ ] point
right yeah and then for its kind of odd
that you're yeah there are the stuff
when you guys opened up and you talked
to each other about certain things those
are probably the moments that you're
that you're cherry-picking that she
probably also appreciated as well but
you're it's a it's a it's a positive and
negative and then the negatives outweigh
the positive is what's happened exactly
and it seems like you're even like with
the rhetoric like the language that
you're using right now is you I thought
that this is what guys were supposed to
do you're not reading the situation
you're not really reading her as a
person right so for example if she's
somebody that if she feels like you'd
really felt like you knew her right and
she had issues of her being sexualized
by people like other men do you think
it's a smart idea that every time that
you talked to her you mentioned how
beautiful she looks something about her
physical size right do you think that
that's very smart yeah there are women
and you'll read tweets and all this of
the [ __ ] like I like it when my man says
this this isn't it that that to me but
you still got to read the individual it
seems like she has issues of people who
want to be around her for either clout
or the fact that she's a very beautiful
woman so you kind of just digging into
those insecurities by every time you're
with her or you're talking to her online
or over the phone and you say and the
the topic of your conversation is how
amazing she looks what the [ __ ] else are
you supposed to think dude yeah and
there's no substance yeah how is how is
this the connection
part is where I'm a little bit lost man
it's like if you're talking about
substance that's not substance that's
you reading this textbook about how to
keep a girl around and make them happy
and then you kind of did this plug-in
plaything well it's actually selfish
because he's like I'm complimenting her
I'm doing this and I'm expressing how I
feel but at the end of the day we want
and then I'm only I'm only talking to my
younger self it's - yeah don't feel
attacked bro we made this [ __ ]
mistake and we're just kind of letting
you know so you can limit how long you
stay in this mental state I want you to
get better obviously that's why we're
being hard on you so when you hear this
don't feel like you're a total failure
see it as an opportunity where someone
slapping the [ __ ] out of you into
reality because here's your opportunity
now to change there's a lot of things
that you're missing and you're not
seeing that's probably why you're asking
us like what's going on and we were able
to see the warning signs because we
personally went through this [ __ ] and we
did the same thing so the goal here is
understanding what a person is saying
male or female doesn't matter and their
intent and in your ability to connect
with them you have a lot of noise going
on in your own mind because your own
voice inside is way louder than what the
person is saying hmm you think hey man
I'm doing the right thing I did what I
was supposed to do textbook one I'm
common yeah I'm complimenting her I'm
making her feel special I'm doing this
I'm doing that why is she going crazy
and all of a sudden [ __ ] acting up
this gets you to fall into the trap of
thinking women are the real rational
women are this when I'm like don't go
into that low level of thinking what it
really boils down to is how come you
weren't connecting what weren't you
listening to she's obviously telling you
and communicating and telling you the
points we were able to see it before you
even explained it the the goal here is
to really understand what people are
saying not everyone is going to be great
at explaining but it's all about
understanding what people really mean
when they're communicating to you yeah
and she's saying yo you had a chance bro
and you blew it
I was kind of communicating with you and
I was waiting for that chance of
connection of whatever but you were so
focused on just living in your own
feelings that you weren't connecting
with my feelings and just doing things
that you thought were positive that you
believed without really seeing how it
was affecting the person that you were
saying these things to right so it's
kind of like this right
imagine if um you know David doesn't
[ __ ] like chocolate but for his
birthday I give him chocolate and I'm
like bro it a gift is a gift why aren't
you [ __ ] grateful like why are you
being selfish like yeah I'm buying you a
gift in the first place like isn't that
good enough but it's like bro I told you
millions of times I don't like [ __ ]
choc I heard [ __ ] fat people like
chocolate
I saw a BuzzFeed article 12 reasons why
fat people love chocolate like I don't
get it bro like what the [ __ ] yeah
alright okay and I thought the girls
appreciated when the person